字幕: Akiko Kamio
校正: Saaya Fujii
(三味線）
(三味線)
（拍手）
皆様どうも こんにちは
津軽三味線の演奏をしております
Niyaです
私はですね 焼尻島という
北海道の北の方にある島で
小学校１年生から中学校３年生までの間
そこで育ちました
三味線を始めるきっかけとしては
たまたま 小学校２年生の時ですね テレビで
何か気になる音があるなと
思いまして自分で調べたら
三味線だという事に気づきまして
その年のクリスマスの日に
サンタさんにお願いをして
そうしたら次の日の朝 枕元に
三味線があったのがきっかけです
それで翌年 日本一三代目の称号を
手にされました佐藤俊彦師と出会い
弟子入りをしてそれから
本格的にスタートしました
焼尻島からですね その師匠は札幌にいまして
月に一度船に乗り バスに乗り通っていました
焼尻には高校がない為どうしても
島から離れなくてはいけなくて
高校１年生から札幌に一人暮らしをしに引っ越し
学校も行きながら三味線をしていました
高校２年生から３年生の間ですね
三味線が凄い嫌いになって
絶対触りたくないっていう衝動にでまして
無断で休んだりとかしてました
たまたま担任の先生に
お前は三味線がないとお前じゃないぞ
という事で その日の夜とても悔しくて
１年半ぶりに師匠に
もう一度やらさせて下さいと
頭を下げたら快く受け入れてくれまして
それから仕事がある度に自分を
連れて行ってもらって
そこで沢山演奏をさせていただきました
その年なんですけど 師匠は東京の公演中に
くも膜下出血で
ステージの上で演奏しながら亡くなりました
その師匠は沢山僕にとても
大切な事を教えてくれました
本日は二つお話をしたいと思います
まずは音楽よりも
人間が大事だと言う事です
幾ら演奏する音楽が素晴らしくても
人間がだめだと生きてはいけない
ましては人間性が良くないと
あるステージに呼ばれなかったりとか
演奏する機会を頂けないというのが
その言葉です
二つ目は「引かぬ殺生」という言葉です
この三味線は沢山の動物を
殺して作られています
例えば糸巻き これは象牙です
そして撥（バチ）はべっ甲
亀です
そして水牛 象牙だったりとか
この胴というんですけれども
ここ皆さん何の動物の皮で
出来ているかご存知でしょうか？
これはですね「犬」なんです
恐らく皆様の頭の中では
「猫」という感じだと思ったんですが
津軽三味線になってからは
「犬」に変わりました
そうやって三味線は沢山の動物を
殺して作られていて
師匠はその動物達に
沢山演奏して
供養をしてやれと それが
大事だという事を教えてくれました
そんな三味線なんですが
今は昔に比べて
皆様が生で聞く機会というのは
恐らく減少していっているのでは
ないかと思います
昔は民謡を聞いて人と人とが
助け合って支え合って
日常のBGMになって
いたんですけれども
今は夏祭り お正月といった
イベントごとでしか
こうやって生で聞く機会はないと
思います
そういった三味線なんですが
この三味線は今も職人さんが
僕の三味線は職人さんが作っているんですが
その職人さんも恐らく増える事はないでしょう
そして今は機械で作られています
そうやって三味線に関係する人たちの場面が
減少していく
増えていく可能性が少ないと言う事に対して
僕はとても不安に思っています
その不安を何とかする為に自分は
まずは民謡
三味線の土台となるものを
しっかりと固めて
その上で様々なジャンルとのコラボ
例えば
ファッションショーのBGM
そして吹奏楽団 クラブでの演奏
そういった場面で演奏して
身近に感じてもらう
その他にでも 今も自分はたまに
やっているのが
若い人達に教える 感じさせる
そしてまた三味線というのは
パフォーマンス 演奏だけではなくて
パフォーマンスとして見せる事もできます
そういった場面で 沢山様々な
ジャンルとコラボしていく
それは 日本でする事も
凄い大事なんですけれども
僕は海外でやりたいです
日本はとても影響されて
生活も西洋化されていってそして
ちょっとワンテンポ遅れて日本で流行ったり
というのが自分の中であると思うんです
こういった日本の伝統楽器というのは
海外で物凄く高く評価されています
そういう効果を使って海外からそして
日本へ持っていきたいなと思います
それが僕の夢です
何とかして日本の伝統音楽を
皆様に身近にさせていきます
ぜひ僕だけではなくて
日本人である皆様にも
その日本の伝統音楽を
魅力を感じてほしいです
それが僕の中にある
思いの音楽で
皆がつながる「You & I」 だと思っています
今回は三味線を持っているので
これからは 今日はサポートの人を連れて
洋と和でセッションをしたいと思います
じゃあ呼びます
KENGO beatsというデジタルパーカッションを
扱う人を呼んでおります
どうぞ
（拍手）
（三味線の音）
聞いてください　「TO NORTH」 （北へ）
という曲を演奏します
（パーカッション）
（演奏）
（手拍子）
（拍手）
ありがとうございました
(拍手)